so why da Haiti what were you here I  wanna chase adventures hello is this guy  [Music]  buckle what's a life sign out there own  life  you're either sleep-deprived or seasick  and after a few days there's that loosen  ations why did it it's a feeling I can't  describe this you and infinite horizon  how would you like to sail it has Haneda  kind of long givers what do you think I  think four thousand miles is insane  I'm not going anywhere without you I'm  saying with me  [Music]  [Music]  thousands of miles from land bring on  any flight paths that's like a 1,500  square miles for cheerio needle in a  haystack  my ribs burning my legs shove it I'm  dead weight he's out of Hawaii say that  2008 the movie the target if you miss  Hawaii that's why we died I can't do  this you could do anything you put your  mind to  settled halfway around the world to find  you  I'm not  you  you